[Music]
let's start at the beginning of how the
two of you came to work together which
was back on that short and could you
talk about sort of your early experience
working together in the the origins of
the project back then
sure sure so
in
project involve i was in the
directing tract
um and
katie was in the writing track and so
the way it worked was um
the writers wrote scripts and then the
directors pitched on
on scripts i can't remember if we were
if we had certain ones we could pitch on
if we could pitch on any of them that we
wanted but i think you could pitch on
any we we had talked fairly early on
like because you know
we were all encouraged as part of the
program for anyone i guess who doesn't
know what project involved entails it's
it's
they choose uh roughly
six of each track so there's like a
directing track editing cinematography
writing and what's the last one
directing
producing producing yeah producing
thank you
so they they choose
they choose roughly six of each and so
we were encouraged for the first few
months of the program to get to know
each other's work
and so you know i he had read some of my
stuff and i had watched his
stuff and and we before we got into
writing the scripts and coming up with
the story ideas
um yeah we we got to know each other a
little bit more and i i went into
i came up with this idea and i remember
pitching it to you and to jonik who was
the producer of our short and you know i
think we like we talked about it before
you started pitching on it
so
that was yeah that was cool yeah but i
was yeah it was it was yeah but i was
still like um
i was scared to
of this project because it was a
humorous take on something that was very
serious but
i also thought that was what made it
special was that it was looking at it
through a different lens and um
i i remember
angel christy williams was uh
one of our advisors or like she was
running the program and she
she told me to watch this short called
five deep breaths i believe it was and
uh that really focused on it was sort of
a similar thing but not as humorous but
it really focused on the friendship of
these young men as like the heart of it
and i was like oh shit that really is
the way in um and i'm forever grateful
for uh to her for showing me that
because that really kind of made me like
focus
um for the short so i i pitched on it
and you know and yeah we got paired it's
funny because we didn't we we kind of
pre-talked about it a little bit but it
was it was really in the program's hands
of pairing us
together so
thanks film independent
so
the the short films that are made every
year in project involved every year
they're so strong such
such great filmmaking
one of the but they tend to be i
shouldn't say but that they're great and
they tend to be very dramatic and you
know more than comedic pieces and i will
never forget the night watching the
premiere of your short where i mean it's
obviously dealing with some really real
issues but the element of humor just cut
through and was
so unexpected and powerful and great and
it's here in the future as well
we're going to seven parties tonight bro
you should take it easy don't get cool
into any trouble that boy's black
excellence oh come on come on we only
gonna have five minutes when we get back
to pregame change and lead
sean what
where's carlos
there's an unconscious white girl in our
living room what we can't just leave her
somewhere we take her to the hospital
yes
shotgun
[Applause]
i told you we should just call
looks 911 she's in that car what the
hell is going on we don't know who she
is actually she just told me that she's
in high school
[Applause]
think about it statistically
how many people actually get shot by the
cops it's like really really unlikely
right what i'm talking about
when you were writing this did was from
the beginning were you thinking that i
mean is it your sort of your disposition
to approach things with humor or did you
make the conscious decision here that
you really wanted to deal with these
this material through the lens of humor
yeah i think that it was important to
both of us that this
felt
grounded but
that you know i think that we had both
seen a lot of things that were trying to
tackle the issue of you know police and
the tense relationship with communities
of color and um like i'm i'm latina my
my dad's here
he uh he grew up in east l.a and you
know i think that this was something
that
looking at the issue
the thing that interested me was this
idea of
the
the
struggle of like
the the fact that there's a culture of
fear we wanted to talk about the culture
of fear and not necessarily an incident
where somebody
gets shot if that makes sense like there
have been a lot of films that that i had
seen on the short film festival circuit
of like look at how racism is bad and i
think that we were like if you haven't
figured out that racism is bad by now i
don't know what we're going to tell you
we're not going to teach you that so we
wanted to do the short film was was very
much the it was the scene at the end of
act one where they find her and they're
just discussing whether they're going to
call 9-1-1 or not and like it's very
much a contained
uh short and you you get to see their
decision-making process and that that
the the tension of the movie
in the short and in the future
and the thing that the comedy and the
drama are both mined from is that
that fact that these these guys have to
go through this
constant calculus of of trying to figure
out how am i being perceived right now
and like thinking about
do i appear like a threat do i what can
i do to mitigate that is you know it's
very much something that
you know we wanted to talk about and and
that like that's where the comedy comes
from and and it's it's something that we
hadn't seen before
and so i think that like we were aware
of that from the short and so really
very much helped to have that going into
the short and then coming into the
feature film um
so yeah i guess to answer your question
it was always meant to be sort of like
it was supposed to be a little bit of a
cathartic
comedic experience for people who've
been in that position but also have that
sort of thriller spine like a little bit
of that thriller horror like the way it
shot is something that carrie definitely
like brought
yeah i mean you know for me
beyond beyond the short i was excited to
explore their relationship more and also
to touch on the culture fear and anxiety
in young men of color
um and you know i i i felt like if i
just was honest with their
their relationship it was going to be
humorous because of the situations that
katie had written
so i didn't try to push any comedy with
like the way it was shot i just wanted
it to be i wanted it to feel very
authored but not to feel like
it felt like a comedy you know what i
mean because this is a very real
situation for them in this night
so um i try to make it very very author
but not like it feels comedic least shot
if that makes sense yeah we we talked
about it very early on like in the short
and list that this is not a comedy to
them at all like this is the most
horrifying night of their lives and so
we wanted to make sure that that comes
across that it's funny
on on the level of you know from an
outsider looking in it's funny but not
not at all for them at all
right right
carrie could you talk about um
casting for the feature how sort of
after you've done the short you'd learn
so much from doing that and of course
you did another feature in between yeah
um so when you it came time to do the
feature of emergency what ideas did you
have about casting and what led you to
it's a fantastic cast i'm curious how
many assembled it cass is phenomenal i
am so blessed with this cast so i had to
get rj back in there because i had done
a movie called our hashtag jay that he
played uh played benvolio um and uh he's
fantastic so i had to get him back in
there and then we had a really great
casting director kim coleman who um
brought us a lot of people you know she
brought us donald she brought us
sebastian
uh temple hill had a relationship with
sabrina already and so i met with
sabrina and she was super dope and cool
we just like zoomed with each other and
talked about music and
those kind of things and she totally
understood his character and we you know
talked about the character and the
privilege and all that stuff so it
really nicely fell into place i mean i
um you know i feel like you know
everything
from having that having that piece with
rj
as that anchor with sean and then
finding the coon lay with donald who
matched up beautifully with him that
chemistry was so great and then
sebastian coming in and rounding out the
trio
um and then we also you know when we
were in atlanta that's when we when we
got
madison and maddie and diego and kind of
rounded out the rest of the cast
uh there but um it was really it was
really a joy to to cast this film and
and you know after they all came
together they like
clicked so nicely it was
i was like you know with it it's an
ensemble in a lot of ways and like you
really hope they will like gel and and
and really click but uh they really did
so it was it was dope
i i also thought it was really funny
that of the core like the women in the
cast
they're named all of them are named
maddie except the one who plays maddie
yeah that's true
when did when did you film
we filmed this dude literally a year ago
it was like
yeah i mean it was in in
durian pandemic you know it was in
atlanta um god it was like april like
right april april may i guess like
yeah yeah
so i know we're we're sick of covet and
we're sick of talking about it but could
you talk about how that
sort of what your production was like i
mean robin every day yeah swabbing every
day man um it was it was so because you
had a lot of extras you right you have
the minute yeah so that actually stopped
that actually stopped us from shooting
sooner because um you know um amazon
have definitely like you know some
protocols about like how many people
could be in a room at a time during the
pandemic and you know we kept watching
the numbers and all that stuff and when
is it getting better and all that stuff
because we then we explored because you
know for the party scenes we wanted to
feel like this is college party shit
so we explore like you know um special
effects visual effects all that stuff
like i was in there trying to think of
like what if we put cardboard cutouts
with smoke and strobes and shoot through
windows like anything because i was like
we gotta shoot this shit cuz i get
nervous like the longer we don't shoot
the more that shit could not happen you
know so uh i was thinking all this stuff
but you know eventually we were able to
um able to get everything you know we
were able to go there and shoot and
um yeah i mean it was it was there's
definitely this thing of
um with the mask on and like all that
stuff it puts a little bit of a barrier
with like you know things and having to
be distant but
um
you know we persevered i mean you know
we were able to get through it and make
it yeah we were also lucky that it was
like in that tiny golden window right
after the vaccine came out and right
before delta hit so it was like
right there we were like oh it's going
away everything's fine and then right
after production was when
it all went bad again yeah
so that was spring of 21 and the short
came out in 18.
right so
i'm also curious to hear both of you
talk about those are some pretty pivotal
years in the history of
this country and what's going on in the
culture and politically and
um
i mean a lot of
this is clearly a development of the
short and the same themes and the same
material but i'm really curious given
what's been going on in the country how
did
how did
in developing this into a feature
how did it change for you
um
and were there
directions you wanted to push it because
of what was going on politically and
culturally yeah i think that even just
when it came to coming up with the idea
for the short film i remember the
the election happened
right when we started the program at
film independent do you remember it was
like it would happened and then we were
supposed to be writing like we were
supposed to start pitching short ideas
right after the election
and every idea that
we all had i think went out the window
and it was like we need to write
something that's
mean something to us and says something
and
it almost felt like
cathartic
i mean i think for a lot of us working
on
the short film it felt like a cathartic
process and
for the future
i mean we didn't write the the short or
we didn't make the short as a proof of
concept for a feature originally we made
it as a standalone
and
so
the feature film came out of just we we
had gone on the festival circuit and we
were we were i think very surprised at
how people were responding so positively
like i remember people would come up to
us afterward
and and just
you know they would just they were so
like effusive and like
i know grateful it was kind of a strange
thing but uh
for
feeling like represented and
i think that that really made us feel
that we you know we had to do the story
justice in the feature version and you
know i think that like yeah the the
story of how the feature version came
about was that carrie uh basically we
were at we were at sundance and
uh
people
south by yeah and um people started
asking carrie like where's the feature
version and he was like she's working on
it right now i was like oh i guess i'm
working on it right now that's why you
do that's what you do yeah so
so i started you know we thought of it
really early on we knew that it was
going to be one of those one crazy night
stories
um but of course it had to be expanded
and
that was more of an opportunity to tell
a more complicated nuance story about
these
these men and their friendship but also
the the their place in the this you know
political
climate that we're in and you know this
is something we had also been asked many
times
i mean if you recall like
we've been asked so many times
how did you come like you came up with
this idea it's so topical because you
know we started the script we started
like shopping it around around like 2019
yeah
like 2019 i guess and um people were
like it's so relevant and we were like
we this has been a thing in our
communities
forever like this isn't just relevant
now like we we shot the short back in
2017 and like the protests happened and
you know yeah people were like that's
that lens that lends that way yeah
so it's just yeah it's interesting that
i mean this has always been relevant
for the latino community in the black
community yeah so
carrie i wanted to ask you about um
a couple scenes towards the end of the
film that i just thought were
beautifully done one and and i wasn't
one scene i really wasn't expecting was
towards the end the big climactic scene
of their friendship when they come
together when he comes back and they
have that conversation in the in the lab
and
such an intense emotional scene and just
a beautiful uh
embodiment of their friendship in that
moment i'd love to hear you talk about
directing them and how you
what how you what i'm really curious
what kind of atmosphere you create on
set yeah and how just how that scene
came together for you for sure i'd like
to think i create a very safe playful
atmosphere on set
you know if actors have ideas that they
want to try
they feel like they can
so hopefully that
that comes across i think it does
but that scene was
the scene i wanted to shoot the most
like from from jump i was like that's
the scene that i want to see because
that to me
was something i don't see enough
on screen of of two young black men
really being emotionally
open with each other
and telling each other they love each
other in that way
um so
in directing that scene i was
i
i've been it would have been so much
build up to it i was like coming in that
day i was like oh man this has got to be
great
and um it's funny because there's one
like we did a rehearsal and i think the
guys were like so ready for we did a
rehearsal and rj just like
boom like really just went and i was
like oh my god we're not rolling on this
shit like what i and it's it it's it's
in my brain now like forever
this shit is like digital like just roll
everything like i don't know why but
anyway it's beside the point
they're so good they were able to like
bring it back but there was one there
was one moment when um
donald was was doing his take and it was
like maybe like second or third take
and i just went to him and i remember
this and i was like
just talk to your brother because i felt
like i'd seen that relationship build
with him and rj so much over the you
know the few weeks we've done it
that
um
that simple thing would open up
something and i was like don't worry
about the script right now just talk to
your brother and like that is mostly the
take that we use in the movie because it
just was like you know he goes off
script but it's like real emotionally
raw open
um
and that that was just
you know i i i remember going in there
to like say something to him after that
take and when i came back like there was
like a box of kleenex on my like chair
because i had been like like bawling
during the during the thing um but
that's that's it man i mean it wasn't
like we didn't do a lot of takes of that
we didn't do a lot it was just like you
know maybe two or three and just very
simple
you know simple direction i thought that
you know i could maybe give them i think
that's something i started trying to
learn more in this project too was um
say less you know like talk a little
less in like the you know
giving the direction and do
you know i like to do a lot of stuff
beforehand
um like with like talking with the
actors you know and
sharing music and then when we're doing
it
try to like give a little less like
redirection you know if i can
yeah yeah wow
well that scene it's it's remarkable and
you know so much of the film is like
it's up here it's so tense yeah you know
not knowing what's going to happen and
they're just they're going and they're
going and in that moment it's like you
can just see them breathe and the
audience with them it was you know
really
really beautiful and beautifully written
too
um i was i'm also i love the
i don't know if this is the
well right at the end of the movie the
scene went
the two of them come to the door and
sabrina carpenter's character starts to
read her letter i just have to say my
reaction to that
i thought oh she's going to read her
letter and what's he going to say i'm
like leaning in and then he closes the
door and i'm like of course he closed
the door on her like that i don't know i
thought that was a great
great beautifully written moment and
also funny because that's something
where she went on a bit longer in the
script and they that's an edit edit they
they cut her off earlier so good job
editor and director obviously yeah that
i was gonna say should we tell them yeah
yeah no it was it was a longer scene and
it was like they had to endure her
apology and it was a little bit more
excruciating to watch before so yeah i
think it's more cathartic to watch the
yeah i feel like we gave coonley his
agency back in that moment and he needed
that after what he'd been through with
this the way we did it this way
um we did a few different versions of
some things that could happen
with that reading of the
apology
you know
um and we felt like this felt the most
satisfying for kunlei and it's really
like we're in his journey at that moment
so like what's the most satisfying thing
for him in that moment before
that other moment of ptsd is gonna
settle back in for him it felt good to
give him that so that's how he landed on
it yeah i got to write the adr line
though yeah yeah
i'll just leave it in the mailbox yeah
oh yeah that was good yeah but then the
next shot i also thought was beautiful
of just his face where he looks like a
young boy just
happy and like so expressive and then
you hear that siren and it's all back
yeah that was just
beautifully done like just playing it
out on his face i thought was
really remarkable thanks man you know it
it it's very bittersweet because for me
i i really like shawn's look to him too
in that moment because it's it's very
very much like man i don't want this for
you but
i'm also happy that you your eyes are
open you know like you will be better
equipped to navigate this world if you
have a little less
you know innocence
you know in a way um so um that look
that he gives him couple with that look
to camera i think you know or two for
and at one point i was like should we
end on sean but
um i'm glad we stuck with ending it with
cool because it really is about how he's
he's kind of changed and his eyes have
opened yeah it's funny thinking about
that scene was something that was like
that was in the script from the very
first draft of the the jenga tower i
don't know where we i don't like the
yeah where did the jingle come i think
it's because i was playing a lot of
django with my sisters and it's very
dramatic
it's a very dramatic game
um but yeah it's it is one of those
things it's like pure joy and then but
you know it's
it's tragic it's like this you're you're
seeing the loss of innocence yeah
um well lastly i just want to say um i
mean i feel like both of you are just on
such a role i mean katie your
oscar nominee for a short film this year
um yes
that was nuts
yeah and carrie you've had two features
back to back at the covid sundances
so
um yeah yeah you know congrats
um i hope you guys i'm so happy you're
able to see the film tonight with an
audience and i hope during the
theatrical run that you'll get out there
and be able to see it with more
that that experience of seeing it with
with live audiences because it's such a
great film yeah and um congratulations
to both of you and and thank you thank
you for being here thank you for being
part of film independent project
involved and
thank you thank you for the homecoming
man yeah it feels good this is special
we appreciate it yeah thank you
yeah and i just want to say thank you to
my my mom and my dad for coming to the
screening do you think this is the first
time they've seen it in a theater so i'm
excited that's great yeah i can't see
anybody but i know you're out there
all right well thank you so much thank
you
[Music]
i i don't want to steal the the show but
it
it's not project kimbap if we don't
acknowledge the community and uh mai de
la torre where are you
here you are man thank you so much it's
another pi fellow cinematographers they
cannot do it by themselves they need a
community and that's what we do at
project ball have a good night thank you
so much
[Music]
you